iran's president has reacted definedly
to the killing of a leading nuclear
scientist
hassan rouhani blamed israel for the
assassination of mukhsen frakizade
a man suspected of masterminding a
secret nuclear weapons program
rouhani said his death showed that what
he called the depth of the enemy's
despair
and said it would not slow down iran's
nuclear ambitions
moksen fakrisade was killed in an ambush
as he traveled along this road to the
east of tehran
several gunmen are reported to have
opened fire on his car
shortly afterwards a nearby truck
exploded he initially survived his
injuries but later died in hospital
and about 15 seconds later a nissan
pickup truck loaded with explosives blew
up
about 15 to 20 meters away from his car
both inflicted wounds on him that led to
his martyrdom
state media describes him as an eminent
nuclear scientist
he was also a member of the powerful
revolutionary guard
whose job is to guard the country's
cleric dominated system
this is a rare photograph of him with
other senior officials
they were meeting the country's supreme
leader indicating just how powerful a
role he played in tehran
he was also the father of the iran
nuclear program because
he was running this program which as
you know is part of an international
dispute
it's this role that made fakhrisade
enemies in 2018 israel's prime minister
accused iran of covering up an ongoing
nuclear programme
despite promising world powers it was
not pursuing the bomb
and you will not be surprised to hear
that sapond is led by the same person
a key part of the plan was to form new
organizations to continue the work
this is how dr morse in faci head of
project about put it remember that name
fakizade
iran now says it believes israel is
responsible for the killing of the
nuclear scientist
it's acknowledging his death has damaged
its defenses
and is vowing revenge
and for inside on this i'm joined by
guido steinberg an expert on the middle
east
from the german institute of
international and security affairs
uh welcome to the program keto iran is
blaming
israel here and as we saw faculty has
clearly been on israel's radar for some
time but
what do you think prompted the killing
now
well i i think it's uh it's no surprise
that the israelis would want
to assassinate the head of the iranian
nuclear program they have already
assassinated
nuclear scientists between 2010 and 2012
in the last phase of escalation between
iran
and and israel but i think the major
reason right now
is that they still have the support of
the trump administration
politically but perhaps also
operationally
and they want to make it the israelis
want to make it as hard as possible for
president-elect
biden um to start negotiations with the
iranians next year
and iran has vowed to retaliate
uh what kind of form could that take
well the iranians have retaliated in the
past in 2012
i believe that the israeli attacks
stopped when iranians and their allies
mainly lebanese hezbollah attacked
civilian israeli targets so that the
israeli government
decided that the price was too high
for israeli civilians to pay for these
assassinations and i believe
something similar might follow um the
revolutionary guards
might also want to attack american
american israeli targets but in most
cases at least in western countries
they are too weak to target hardened
well-protected targets
you were saying just earlier that one of
the targets
was the scientist of course but also the
policy of president-elect joe biden as i
think the united states plans to to
re-enter the iran nuclear deal how does
this make things more complicated
well the iranian side will have to prove
internally especially to the powerful
revolutionary guards
that they are not giving in
to the pressure campaign by the trump
administration
it will make it extremely hard
this well the pressure campaign and this
event
will make it extremely hard to convince
the iranian leadership that it's
worthwhile
uh to negotiate with the united states
especially because major parts of
the iranian power elite believe anyhow
that the united states
israel and the west in general do not
want them to have a peaceful nuclear
program
okay guido steinberg from the german
institute of international and security
affairs
thanks so much